as the war in ukraine continues to
intensify more than 4 million refugees
have escaped the country anderson woman
has made it her mission to help refugees
who are now stuck at the u.s mexico
border victoria saha caught up with her
as she was bringing supplies there today
she joins us tonight with her story
victoria
ukrainians have been forced to flee
their homes for the last month many
going to neighboring countries and some
trying to make their way here to the
united states but are held up at the
border one henderson woman realized she
needed to help them with crucial
supplies and took the trip down there
today
i was like let's go you know nina
nadinova woke up at the crack of dawn
saturday morning to start her drive to
tijuana i feel like it's a humanitarian
crisis and
no matter what nationality you're from
what country you're from
you have to be a part of this for days
naida nova was collecting supplies such
as clothing dry food and hygiene
products for the ukrainian refugees at
the u.s mexico border they're forced to
you know sit like this for two days in a
chair
you know they have nowhere to sleep and
the kids are bored out of their minds
nadinova is russian she tells us she
felt an urge to stand by the people who
are being hurt by the leader of her
native country it's like kind of like
you have a bad relative who did
something bad and i feel responsible and
i want to make it up to
you know to people who my relatives hurt
she shares with us the devastating
images of the long lines of people
waiting to be seen by immigration and
most who have no choice but to camp
outside the majority of people who are
here they want to go back home you know
the question is will they be able to go
anytime soon i don't think so the
hundreds of ukrainian refugees were able
to escape to mexico because there were
no visa requirements for them but now
they're left waiting to be able to
reunite with loved ones on the other
side of the border
she says she will continue to make more
trips to the border and has also signed
up to take in refugees here in las vegas
if they needed a home